uh I think bomb I think you have to just
accept bombing as part of the creative
process
and uh
once you know
once you bomb it's about that recovery
time after the bomb and what you do
based on the bomb if you bomb and then
be like I'm not gonna write or don't try
to improve now you've let the bomb
win if you bomb and black all right I'm
gonna hear what was happening figure out
what I can do better and then go back
out and try to do it again and then even
if you bomb a second time here's the
thing you bomb enough times you won't be
bombing any longer
it's really that simple I know people
that I've seen bomb for a long time
and then over like the years and a
couple of more times being on stage
never saw them bomb ever again
yeah bombing is an eye the beholder
you know it sometimes you know so I've
seen some Comics bomb and then they get
all flexing like yeah y'all see that
we're like well we didn't hear it but we
definitely saw it
um
but I think it does come down to just
repetition I mean the more you get on
stage it's just the more comfortable
you're gonna be you know and once you
have
more comfort and confidence in your
material
the less that fear of bombing will
appear
but I think yeah I mean I think
especially
I could ask so many questions that
aren't
and the answer is stage time like
like people are always looking for like
well what's the secret to do and I was
like well I've interviewed over 400
comedians I've been a comedian over 12
years
it's getting on stage like you know what
I mean like yeah I'm almost wondering if
you can answer every question with more
stage time and then go into something
else yeah that's like the previous we
preface every answer with you gotta get
on stage you know
but see that's yeah say said I've never
done stand up but once I told a joke to
someone I got no reaction I felt
terrible I can't imagine what it would
feel like on stage
oh it's gonna feel worse
laughs
people are like that's the thing that
was just a one-to-one interaction
imagine happening in front of 20
strangers imagine having in front of a
hundred strangers oh it's it is it is a
death feeling in the pits of your
stomach like a good hearty bomb is like
just it gets all up in there you know
but then once you experience it you
realize oh it's not that bad
it's not that bad yeah and it's it's
you're it's just stage time like once
you're so once you get used to just
working your material
then the bombing is just a part of the
process
Stan I think it helps to also understand
that it everyone bombs and everyone goes
through struggling on stage so yeah
congrats you're a comedian that's part
of being a comedian is being able to
handle those moments and get back up
even if you don't feel like it at the
time
yeah good point but say hasn't been on
stage yet so it's like yeah you got to
get on stage
yeah yeah like the thing that you're
like afraid of at the moment of just
what happens if I bomb
yeah
you figure it out like that
once you go through it now you know what
happens when you bomb
and now you can figure out what you do
afterwards but yeah there's no amount of
lip service that we can pay to tell you
just get on stage the key to being
successful and stand up is stage time
and a lot of it and